Determine whether the
system has no solutions
or infinite solutions.
So they're telling us right
from the get go that we're not
going to have one nice,
clean solution here.
So let's just try to
solve this system.
And so to solve
the system we want
to eliminate one variable first.
So let's say we want to
focus on eliminating,
let's eliminate the x's.
So if we want to
eliminate the x's,
if I multiply this
first equation over here
by negative 4, then this
will become a negative 8x
which should be able to cancel
out with this 8x over here.
So let me multiply
it by negative 4.
So times negative 4.
So 2 times negative
4 is negative 8x.
Negative 4y times
negative 4 is plus 16y.
Negative 4 times
z is negative 4z.
And then that is going to be
equal to negative 4 times 3
is negative 12.
And then let me just
rewrite the second equation
right over here.
We have 8x minus 2y
plus 4z is equal to 7.
And now we can add
these two equations
and hopefully
eliminate the x terms.
Negative 8x plus
8x, they eliminate.
16y minus 2y is 14y.
And then negative 4z plus
4z, those also eliminate.
We were able to eliminate and
x and a z in one fell swoop.
And so we get 14y
is equal to-- we
have negative 12
plus 7 is negative 5.
We have negative
5, just like that.
And actually, we
could solve this.
This is one equation
and one unknown.
But we haven't used the
third constraint yet.
We haven't used this
constraint over here.
So we have-- we could
actually solve it.
Just divide both sides by 14 and
we get y is equal to negative 5
over 14.
So that's interesting,
but it doesn't necessarily
tell us much about
the solution just yet.
You want to be very careful
about back substituting
and all of that,
because we haven't
used all of the constraints yet.
We still haven't used
this third constraint.
So our goal was to eliminate
x's from the get go.
So let's still try to eliminate
x's using these second two
constraints and see if we
get anything interesting.
And the reason why I'm
being especially wary
is because they're telling
us that this thing either
has no solutions or an
infinite number of solutions.
So let's use these
second two constraints.
And we can eliminate
the x here if we
keep the first
equation the same.
And we multiply the
second equation by 2,
because this will become
a negative 8x which
will eliminate.
So our first equation is just 8x
minus 2y plus 4z is equal to 7,
just rewrote it.
And then the second
equation over here.
I'm going to multiply it by 2.
Negative 4x times
2 is negative 8x.
y times 2 is plus
2y, positive 2y.
Negative 2z times
2 is negative 4z.
And then negative 14
times 2 is negative 28.
And something very interesting
is about to happen.
When you use these
two constraints, when
you try to find the
intersection, essentially,
between these two planes, you
get something very bizarre.
8x minus 8x is 0.
Negative 2y plus
2y is another 0.
4z minus 4z, another 0.
And 7 minus 28 is negative 21.
So using these two
constraints, you
get this kind of nonsensical
statement or inconsistent
statement that 0 is
equal to negative 21.
This obviously can never happen.
So this is, we end
up with no solution.
If we got something like
0 is equal to 0, or 21
is equal to 21, or
negative 21 is equal to 21,
then it would mean that we have
the same exact planes which
would mean we have an
infinite number solutions.
In this circumstance right here,
we have the same coefficients.
But when you add them
up in this weighted way
you get a different result.
So these are actually going
to be parallel planes.
So if you were to graph
this plane and this plane,
one would look
like that and then
the other would look like this.
And so that the only way
that they could intersect
is if 0 is equal to negative 21.
And we know that's impossible.
They never, ever intersect
these two planes.
So regardless of this first
constraint and all of the stuff
we did here, these two
planes will never intersect,
these two right over here.
And so we have no solutions.